[Music]
in celebrity tax evasion news Oh some
what's the sideshow least nice a blade
is on Netflix again oh I love late guess
you'll never guess Pauly Shore like his
last name is related to this carrot top
sure yeah submitted by skinny David yes
you skinny or David Paul Mooney
sure is the word that's related to this
Oh
Jersey Shore
situation yeah that guy Mike the
situation Sorrentino can't open any new
bank accounts as he awaits prison why
and why is he called the situation
because himself the situation when he
walks into a party there's a situation I
forgot everyone except for Polly's nuts
Snooki that's it that's all I remember
there's one oh my - Babs are here okay
yeah I mean they're all pretty buff
right Ron's gonna always like got
emotional with his girlfriend Sam that
guy and he gets into fights and a meme
happen when said you don't know member
the mean it's a good guilty pleasure
it's such a way I just remember slippy
because she just looked like crispy pork
belly out of the oven yeah interesting
sighs the hot body check her out her
name JWoww yeah JWoww can we see what
they look like the caster's horse I mean
back then dis Jersey Shore back then cuz
I'm trying to remember hottest one she
was look it was really short
yeah she's not sure she was a meatball
she was chubby she's not chubby anymore
now she's taller realized she was should
be all got their lips done they're like
you got either Botox oh they got a lift
reminded me of like a four-foot girl man
Oh Nicole ah okay I remember me
her name Jamie veiny yeah remember cold
yeah but what's up the girl's name
so won't the one that's added last Deena
Deena damn you're good oh yeah I love
today's show normal dude yeah like a
straight man dad he said you would look
like him oh I thought it was Paul Paul
DJ Pauly looky Benny don't know the
situation this dude yeah yeah situation
Paul Feeny
Ron Deena cement or Sam Snooki JWoww if
you like their father the father crazy
he's 36 years old you know it's funny
cuz like they're white but they don't
come off as I forget that they're white
the Italian yeah I guess you know that
like noses its Godfather [ __ ] he looks
like he could smell trouble with that
last name yeah they all end with vowels
yes that's me his nose group for sure
right no he's a liar yes oh he has now
been sentenced to eight months in prison
and two years of supervised release in
this tax evasion case eight months in oh
that's gonna be a white-collar prison
the right tax evasion he's not gonna go
to one of those like so he goes to
prison and gets [ __ ] up and he has to
join a gang and [ __ ] and fen-phen for
his [ __ ] I can't go do it yeah last
night yeah and his brother also pleaded
guilty and so it charged them with
aiding in preparation of a false and
fraudulent tax return oh so they were
lying yeah they were lying about their
expenses or whatever was they failed to
properly pay taxes on 8.9 million
dollars in income from 2010 to 2012
that's some nice [ __ ] coin though
yeah some change some gua pepino yeah so
now they're saying that he so he has a
fiancee and I saw that episode
did you see it [ __ ] oh yeah yeah when
you proposed to it oh like one season
they went to Miami right yeah oh and
they have the reunion things the family
vacation or some [ __ ] yeah the family
vacation look where we have kids now but
we can still party how the harsher
they're still pretty morning you are a
fan of the show bro did you ever go to
Vegas to watch DJ Pauly no it all sucks
you in though does it yeah it's actually
it's we're just so mindful and that this
group of people exists their mindset
like it's just so interesting going into
their world remember like when they
watch our vlogs and watched a movie oh
my god Alex oh that would be a thing
like you'd be like your guys's minds are
[ __ ] crazy right you know GTL stands
for gym tan laundry oh I've heard of
that saying GTL yeah wait Gym tan
laundry laundry
that's her routine every day can I go
and do laundry every day yes I look
fresh yeah I look fresh so they hit the
gym
and they go outside on the porch answer
look good they look fresh go clubbing
and all the fist pumping yeah yeah
wait so in the episode they're like
drawing clothes and [ __ ] everything
out talking in shape
yeah after a gym workout GTL they know I
like reality TV though which one you
know which one naked it afraid yeah
Paris you know what I really like the
the [ __ ] Osborne's man that [ __ ] was
dope - I like that one I think it'd get
a little bit frustrated cuz I couldn't
understand yeah it was rough man oh my
I used to like watching Flavor Flav
dollar was way to New York when they
microwave the chicken now I remember
oh man see I feel like I was interested
in these shows and I know enough about
them to know they exist but I maybe I
have watched a couple episodes but I
don't remember him anymore I just
remember the one where I like Tiffany
was spat at from that white girl when
they were walking that was like iconic
reality TV moments right there that
prime reality yeah I never got into the
real world I loved that I watched every
single real little bit
world and Road rules dan you could stay
in a real world sweet and at the Palms
in Vegas I said did you guys watch that
other one big brother no I don't like it
my brother like that's what's bad your
big brother thank you
yeah my big brother like big brother I
know I don't know what the concept of it
was by know a bunch of random people
lived in the same that's about it and
they would [ __ ] each other something
there's no challenge it's yeah that's
literally it
I think like the you came on people
would have sex and [ __ ] they was showing
or so she I remember that or something
like that so they show a little bit of
that most really like you can see the
girl get on top or you'll see like the
silhouette for like a couple seconds
it's really fast what was that show that
um they got a bunch of be less
celebrities in the house but they were
all addicts oh thank you no lies oh yeah
it was like we have in shape dr. drew
yeah it might be but it was ridiculously
funny tantrums yeah
like white rapper watch like the first
sees like the first it didn't last long
yeah not the season like this is the
first episodes and they started like
acclimating themselves to the house and
then I get bored I watch the rest I
watch Top Model a lot o tide like Tommy
I would watch that's true alright watch
that a lot dude but you were on it I was
about to do oh you that's right you know
that yeah I auditioned for it I made the
finals and then my parents are like nah
he not do what yeah I know
like maybe 30 40 miss dude because they
thought it was Mexico and they're like
my daughter's not sucking no producers
yeah like you ain't no puta
you're not gonna be doing [ __ ] like that
yeah I like audition I did everything um
maybe like 20 I was like in college I we
weren't even doing JK at the time and I
was like Jill's gonna be a [ __ ] movie
star well that's pretty 2007 yeah before
I met you guys that was it when you met
us Oh cuz it also you told the story
sort of been like how we knew okay
2005-2006 you would have been on one of
America's top model and your parents
robbed it from you they're all pretty
hot
do you would have straight-up had
Instagram followers right now I would've
been the [ __ ] of the house I know it
oh that was the person idea what he gave
you I'm sure you always not play a role
yeah yeah drama still a [ __ ] about your
skinny ass legs rocky buta [ __ ] out of
your bro put that put that put that put
that with that we should have put
cameras in the video house and they've
died and they would be talking [ __ ]
about you you know that girl [ __ ] geo
[ __ ] she's ours reality TV show would
have been great like you wanted to rig
the house with cameras we had this
[ __ ] most ridiculous [ __ ]
roommates me why don't we do that we
should all just live together for a
month and see what comes out of that no
probably pretty entertaining
it'd be so boring cuz it's all chill
yeah now cuz we worked out all of our
problems in [ __ ] but like we bring our
20 year old selves together
you mean whoopee oh my god man some
[ __ ] up roommate situation that show
would just be like wow David really
doesn't work you're just watching uh
what is it Family Guy why does this fool
just like do nothing during the day and
then he works from my 9:00 p.m. to 4:00
a.m. that's so [ __ ] stupid don't lie
you don't worry hey man you should see
me from 9:00 p.m. to 4:00 a.m. it's
working is shopping on Amazon hey who do
you think [ __ ] edits my own videos
alright dude that would be kind of fun
huh get like a big-ass mansion and then
like all of us just live in there make a
show out of it it would just yeah I'm
trying to picture what everybody would
be doing yeah you guys are all working
as [ __ ] don't be no drama though we
gotta have you gotta have drama I think
the worst dramas gonna be like man how
come you leave [ __ ] dishes in the
[ __ ] in the sink no my bad bro never
do that again they want you right now
I'm sorry I'll cook today that's the
drama
yeah what's David gonna cook today it's
just Leia and Tyco fighting each other
yeah we have to have Joel grabbing bats
I don't know this yeah I wonder all the
way you holding a house what would you
be doing what would they be watching you
do yelling and I think they'd be
wondering what both of us do huh
you know what you guys would see though
you guys would see me sit down trying to
write scripts for like [ __ ] and there's
me cursing a lot when I have a [ __ ]
writer's block cuz I'm like [ __ ]
[ __ ] I get [ __ ] mad my [ __ ]
laptop is [ __ ]
and I go out I go for a walk and I come
back on my best tight I delete a [ __ ]
[ __ ] like that [ __ ] but I go back
outside if this was real real I'll never
be home only when I sleep and then I
make dinner and then me and just cook
together that's it so we'll never see
you yeah I wouldn't be around maybe on
the weekends
how would that yeah I think that would
be most of us it would be do whatever we
do outside inside the house the reality
shows just our pets because you know
those reality shows no one's ever
working yeah like what the [ __ ] people
work that's why they're there cuz that
is their word to interact and create
drama no one questions that though no
one goes like yeah they're gonna go work
and then come back on
rules they were job um when we're just
talking about this guy
Oh Jersey yeah they do have jobs oh yeah
t-shirt time nobody I would like to
choose a role that I would do and it
would just be eating food baby food and
making food so you're like the house
cook yep
and I'll be upset I'd be upset if I cook
dinner and you guys come hella late I'm
like well the [ __ ] food is cold now
so it doesn't matter oh I want to be the
house mystery stain where you guys come
home and then there's just like a pile
of [ __ ] in the corner and everyone's
like oh [ __ ] dude this and you know they
always have the camera zoom ins and the
toys like panning across and then it'd
have been in your cut to like my eyes
and I'm like oh no he's like the worst
editing - because it's like there's no
continuity sure the editing is yelling
and then everyone's like crying in the
corner and then you cut - then they're
laughing oh did you watch the one with
um what was the one they're making fun
of him Ray J he's not a reality TV and
his beanie move like 32 funny if you use
probably going like this in the
conversation like yo man yeah well then
it just cuts and it just cuts in and
it's good do a hundred percent though
like not even [ __ ] kidding you that's
like some hood black [ __ ] dude like when
you have you seem like these dudes on
Instagram I'll I'll of fatherhood ask
people they'll yell Real Talk man now
let me talk to you real quick though you
owe me this do man
yo straight up the hook I don't know why
her - black dudes always do that [ __ ]
when they're talking they always in to
adjust their hat when they're trying to
say something poignant
I don't get that yes sure yeah Real Talk
man just I'm just saying man my mom's
the other day bro yeah just le [ __ ] them
you should have an Asian thing the
ancient things my our dog you know sir
like real dog like let me tell you
straight up I will tell you right now
like all right yeah just gonna keep
going back and forth like dude like for
real though like all right so like maybe
like top man real taco
real talk real talk for real
[Music]